Announcing the great ghost maid of the East.
She is a wild one with her wild hair.
You know her as the minkster.
The freak.
Yes, they say.
Oh, chat is broken.
She is here with one request.
Two pennies.
The one.
The only.
Me.
Hello,
everybody.
Oh, howdy.
Two pennies for Minky.
I think that's more than two pennies.
Oh, I'm liking the 200 pennies.
I'm out a little out of my brain today.
My birthday just passed this weekend.
happy birthday sorry i missed it happy happy birthday the
mini minky no full size every time hello minko and i was
like you she's here and she's ready to bark oh yeah ah the
imagine imagine this chibi minto as like uh as like you know
minku minku miko da yo you know miko da yo imagine me like
that like a big big big
Big...
big...
Character.
Yubi Koi, thank you so much for the...
Five gifted, thank you!
Junto!
That's... Junto, Minto...
Usto?
Bro, thank you!
Or a Minto bonk is just what the doctor ordered for me.
Thanks for the two pennies!
They're so shiny!
If you squint it, it looks like two pennies.
a little
more my pockets are going to be jingling jangling that's
maoshi hey me until today i got a tattoo of you with arch
from roving toda a tattoo
what did you post it i want to see wait that's kind of
terrifying though Wait, what?
I'm happy.
So, so, man, man.
Thank you.
Darko, thank you.
Minky's head crew three sizes that day.
Xenophil, thank you.
Fake D, thank you.
Scuba Gator, thank you.
I hope you're having a lovely day in spite of getting
temporarily exercised.
Yeah, someone, some, some mean prankster poured salt by my
door of the maid cafe.
I guess maybe rumor has it that the place is haunted.
and maybe some horrible priest or something came, poured
some salt, and I was locked out.
Luckily, it rained.
And then the salt dissolved.
Yippee!
Tattoo of Mint Phantom.
They call that Inky Manky.
Is this a penny?
Yeah, close enough.
Mita, it's so much fun of your karaoke and fan of my thank
you.
No, thank you, Nexi!
Sorry you got salt locked.
Hope some mega bonking can help you relax.
Yeah, I'm a little...
I'm a little tired after the whole...
After the whole ordeal.
But, um...
Happy to be back home.
Just don't say...
Yo.
Don't say that.
Oh, sure.
Who said it?
Me.
I am my own worst, not...
I'm not my own...
I am my own enemy.
You're making me odd.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Hold on, let me take another shippie.
What if we turn this into a napping stream?
Wouldn't that be so silly?
I did Fandomay this past weekend.
Um, I was a guest of honor.
Not the why word.
Oh, the why word.
I know what it stands for.
I did Fandomay this past weekend.
I had a lot of fun if I saw any of you guys there.
Thank you so much.
I had Q&A and I did karaoke panel and I learned I had no
idea that during the convention the park con was happening
that people were outside and cannibalism was happening and
how many minutes is that 10 minutes 49 seconds into the
stream there was cannibalism and then Other stuff.
I have no idea what is a park con.
There were people set up outside the convention of Faname.
And they were...
They were playing games?
Like someone set up a racing simulator to their... to their
car?
Good job.
You didn't have to fight a certain two brothers.
That would be awful near the salt line.
It would be.
Yeah, they had barbecue.
And then there was some not-so-favorable things that
happened as well.
The barbecue is not the cannibalism.
The cannibalism was the face-biter that apparently was
happening.
Oh, it's just so...
I don't...
I didn't know about any of this until I was told, literally
today...
I was told about this today and they were like, it was all
over Twitter.
I was like, I'm not browsing Twitter.
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm doing.
And I'm just...
I'm like, what's...
I did not even see a single post about it or anything.
But...
What the heck?
the zombie outbreak finally started i had no context for
anything except what was told to me
i wasn't among the fortunate ibu that won the mean greet i'm
sorry i have great time seeing at the karaoke panel thank
you for coming and watching i really appreciate it yeah i
didn't i thought the mean greet was going to be one of those
like uh everybody lines up and we get through as many as we
can.
I did not realize that it was going to be like a lottery
type system, which those make sense.
But at the same time, I'm also always like, oh man, because
I know when I lose the lottery, it's so sad.
But you have a most Fushiki afterlife YouTuber.
That's not me.
I'm not doing anything.
Howdy, Minto.
I hope you're doing well.
Have you ever tried the game Everything is Crab?
I feel like it'd be your kind of game.
I've heard about it, I think.
I'm nervous about the Off-Kai lottery.
There's a lottery at Off-Kai?
I will try and do as many meets as I can at the Off-Kai.
So that many people have many chances.
Your opinion's on the auction?
My opinion's on the auction.
For those who don't know, I made puppets on stream.
Me and Dan said, too.
And the puppets were on an auction.
Auction for charity.
And they went for...
Six...
thousand seven hundred dollars
never underestimate any eyeballs i tried up to 1k even that
alone is way too much do not time six the eyes
The charity of is a make-a-wish.
A make-a-wish foundation.
Don't look now, me though.
I think we might love you.
I thought I was a big spender, but Toby put me in my place.
No, that is a...
Nope.
Stupid.
Glad the puppets are going to a good home.
I'm not...
so terrified they should not be worth that much they're made
of felt I spent like I spent like $30 to make them I
spent like I spent like shout
out to Toby the six thousand seven hundred Queen for
recognizing the greatness of the handicraft supporting the
cause and sticking to the bit the value is in the fact you
made them because we love you silly ghost
memorial day how exactly do we remember you what are you
talking about confused on afterlife live streams on this day
don't worry about it ahem handcrafted artisanal theater
puppets I will give you guys a hint not a hint but I will
tell you something you have not seen the last of the puppets
the puppets will return when you least expect it made a felt
felt like love I'm sure no when you added six $6,670 by
making them.
I don't think so.
I at least expect them to return right this moment,
personally.
What if?
I mean, obviously, I'm like so happy that that amount goes
to charity.
I wouldn't, I will never, I will let you guys know, I will
never do an auction thing.
that like that unless it's for charity I feel so entirely
icky like if that were to go to me I would be so upset so
anytime it's like a anytime it's like a auction thing like
that it's always gonna go to charity
I would not I would not do that but I'm also like Please
Please be Responsible with your money Apparently Steiner
told me that afterwards Because my manager was there He told
me that Afterwards the Make-A-Wish Foundation Like rep that
was there Went up to him And asked him to personally thank
me.
I didn't do anything!
And apparently, it was the most of any item that has gone in
the auction at Fatima ever.
Switches said so crazy.
Apparently, I also drew a Shikishi.
And that also went for a hefty sum.
So thank you to the Aibu.
Who also auctioned for the Shikishi.
Yeah, $4,000 more dollars.
So...
$10,000 went to charity this weekend.
which is really awesome overall so I mean it was two people
but you know um you know I'm I I'm always so proud of our
community like I was I always say I was of the absolute best
so
you did do something you cultivated a very generous fandom
clearly what do you mean you made the glorious puppets you
literally did everything i did not i did not i mean i made
them yes but like i did not do that that might your
responsibility is a form of responsibility that's a
dangerous slippery slope good job i'm making 67 billion for
charity boss no you literally made the puppets that's like
at least 90 of all the work i mean i was really happy to
make them i would i will make more in the future i'm happy
to make them i think it's fine and they're very silly minto
too powerful no i don't want the great responsibility oh no
rest in peace my granny blew up by his bazooka the auction
pulled in 23k total and 10k if that That was Minto
motivated.
That's insane!
Thanks to you for inspiring us.
That's so fun!
Remember Uncle Ben Minto.
Oh!
Kaboom, kaboom, kaboom, kaboom, kaboom, kaboom!
Kaboom, kaboom!
Kaboom!
But, um, yes, so...
Uh...
Yeah, uh, yeah.
Just...
Oh!
Ah!
Actually, speaking of puppets, I gotta start working on
more.
Mm-hmm.
With great power comes great mint ability.
Time for bonk?
We should bonk, we should bonk, we should bonk.
We should bong I have thought about like doing a like a some
sort of charity thing like some sort of charity donothon and
like you know I match whatever you guys donate something
like that because not well it's like obviously I want to
donate to charity but I think it's a lot of fun if you may
have, like, the reward tiers.
Does anyone think that it's kind of fun to be like, oh, if
we reach this amount, we can do this or something like that.
Those are kind of fun.
That's why it works.
You can't match what we donate.
Why not?
Wait.
I would set it, I would set the cap as like the max thing
for the pro, maybe.
Well, okay.
I boo my bankrupt you.
My
boo's are too strong.
What if an oil baron I boo don't, it's a million?
No one has oil here.
I don't think.
You match it by providing rewards, I'd be...
No!
Nixit, you are banned.
Nixit, you are banned from it.
I will get your IP address and ban you specifically.
No, don't ban me!
If you do that, you'd better cap it.
Two people did over 10k on their own yesterday.
I feel like it would be cool.
a veterans charity.
Oh yeah!
MGS-A's combat stream.
Something like that would be nice.
I've always wanted to do one for this one aquarium.
The Monterey Bay Aquarium.
I don't know, like I just really, I'm really into like ocean
conservation and stuff like that, so that's always what I've
wanted to do a a don't-o-thon for.
Yeah.
Oh, it's the oceans, the oceans.
Save the animals.
But yeah.
Maybe one day.
Not, well, not maybe.
One day, eventually.
I've been talking, I've been thinking about it for a long
time, though.
I just gotta get around to organizing it.
Yeah.
Okie dokie.
Shall we bonk?
It's been a matter since I played it.
What did I...
Who the heck are you?
Thorns tome to level 9.
We've done some of these guys.
We've done...
Oh, I haven't done...
I haven't done bones even once.
Not a single run.
Sir Umphi.
I can't remember who I liked so much.
I'll be doing wonderfully.
Thank you, Brandon.
You too.
I haven't tried it.
Maybe we should just...
We'll just get into it with this guy.
Default calcium.
Oh, he throws a bow.
Let's just try.
Oh.
Oh, we're on tier three.
That's terrifying.
Hold on.
Let's go to tier two.
while I get back into it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look, there's a guy there.
Sick.
Oh, sick!
Ocean, into Ocean Conservation, too.
I knew I liked you for a reason.
Yeah.
Let's do more.
What's the region?
good.
Sorry, I'm gonna be asking a lot of questions again.
I'm more into ocean conversation.
I love talking about the ocean and the seas.
HP per minute.
We'll do more about them.
Hey, check this out.
Bet you never seen that before.
Styling on them.
styling on him.
Oh!
Watch this.
Almost had him.
Huh!
Oh!
I'm too good.
What do you have?
Ghost.
Phantom Shroud.
After evading, deal two-time damage next attack and
temporarily increase attack speed and movement speed.
I want Ghost.
But also, Phantom Shroud.
That's literally my name.
Chill out guys, chill out.
There's enough of me for all of you.
More shield!
Quantity toome!
Ouch.
Ocean conservation.
You can have that one.
And two dubs.
Thanks, Unk.
I can't believe Minky is boning live on stream.
I'm always boning.
ammo is oh wait we can unlock that guy
quantity wait or should i get the evasion though
quantity quantity i got swords now they've evolved 30 i'll
open it
sure Oh yeah, we gotta go find the...
Sick.
Oh yeah, I forgot there's damage in this.
Or fall damage, I mean.
Attack speed!
I think a cooldown tome.
Wait, shield?
Question me, though.
How did you get to be so cool?
To be cool like me?
You gotta eat your carrots and your green beans.
I shield with calcium?
Okay, okay.
Is he...
Is he a sense...
Is he really...
You know...
He's easy to break.
Okay.
He kind of brittle.
He needs more calcium.
Wargose.
Look at all these guys.
Oh, I'm gonna do the live still.
Let's go find us.
Finally home.
Unplanned, but I got to stick fight for 14 of the last 36
hours.
I dedicate my bonk powers to you, Bossu.
And I thank you forever.
Thank you, Rising Glutraise, and welcome home.
Baby!
More bone.
Maybe banish knockback.
Oh, banish knockback.
I think so.
Oh, I forgot to banish it.
That's okay though.
Bees!
Give me cash.
Give me cash, everybody.
And I'm gonna open this bad boy too.
Knock.
Cheese!
Beast.
Oh, another key.
Wait.
Sorry, I thought I saw something, but I did a...
Alright.
Mulai!
I'm gonna go to him.
Or first, I'm gonna do this.
Are you saying we need to take our vitamins and...
Oshikots?
What?
Yes.
Um, only gamers pick this one.
Wait, what if I...
Wait, what do I eat if I want to be smoking?
You shouldn't smoke?
Definitely don't eat your cigarettes.
Solid Snake is a terrible influence.
I guess we'll do thorns.
I guess.
Why?
Quantity.
I'm going with a luck tone.
I'm not listening to anything anybody ever says.
I'm all in on luck, baby.
Wait, what is that?
Ah!
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
I think I might just keep going, Jim's house.
Instructions unclear.
Need six pumps for my tummy.
No!
Oh, oh my god.
Where'd that guy come from?
Outs!
Ah!
Ow!
It's okay.
It was just a warm-up.
Brush your sleep.
Get eight hours of drugs every day.
No, no, no!
Those are the wrong order!
You're supposed to eat your teeth, get eight hours of drugs
every day, and brush your sleep!
No, no, no!
Okay, let's try again.
Tier 3.
I'm ready.
Freddy.
I've known Mr. Bones for one...
second and I'm ready I think we're best pals is this a free
one oh yeah I was playing mega bank while you were salt
block no Bush did me in before stream too no cheese we're
gonna cheese stack everybody this is the cheese run we're
cheese and a guy
I heard you were supposed to drink your drugs, stay in milk,
and don't do school?
School.
Power up drop chance?
Probably would be good, right?
Early cheese.
That was Phanamecon.
It was so fun!
School.
Get HP.
More jump?
HP?
Okay, I'll do HP.
Oh!
We'll do...
I'm like, what weapons do I want?
You know?
More bones?
Yeah, I think we're getting more...
We need more projectiles.
That's so true.
Wait.
Oh, I don't need that magnet just yet.
But there was a guy down here that we will, we'll get to.
It's early.
I think luck would be good.
I think luck would be good, no.
Go bullet hell route.
And then I'm going to do luck.
Should I do the clover?
Wait, okay, hold on.
I'm stuck between Clover and Time Bracelet.
I think I've got more luck.
I changed my mind.
Wait, where is everybody?
Can you guys like all show up?
I gotta do the cool...
Why so bones, Minto?
I think skeletons are so silly.
was going to do the cooldown.
I almost wanted the chunksters, but I think cooldown is
better for our weapon at the moment.
Uh, alright, let's go find us.
A, uh, so far I feel like we haven't really gotten so much
though.
Is it just me?
I feel like last game I was getting lots of stuff.
Oh hell.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, that's the jukebox.
Free.
Oh, thanks.
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
I love the banana.
I don't...
Idle juice.
The longer you stand still, the more damage you do.
Oh, okay.
I'll take it, I guess.
But right now, we're searching.
Where's that?
Where's that big guy?
Did I take him out already?
I guess so.
Whoa!
Come here.
I wish I could aim at him.
No, no, no!
I'm thinking aura.
Aura.
I kind of want sword, but I'm gonna do aura.
Let's kill this guy.
Yeah!
Wait, it's like everything that I could want.
Aura, Aura.
I think I'm going to go more...
I'm like, Bone or Cool Down?
Let's do Cool Down.
Cool Down's good.
Oh, hello.
Oh my gosh.
That guy fell right on me.
Holy cow.
I'm going to Aura.
Or aura farming?
Oats.
Uh-oh.
Now, like, don't die.
I
have to get rid of the oats.
It's a bad song.
There's no way!
Okay.
I'm giving this guy one more time.
Come on, Calcium.
I believe in you.
Tier 3, we got it.
It's so goofy.
So darn goofy, man.
Oh.
More bowed.
Oh, projectile speed.
Wait, that would be good, though, with my bones.
And if I get the bananas, too.
Remember to use control this.
Oh, it was control.
That's right.
Thank you.
They lied about Oats being healthy.
Two?
I want the speed.
But this is uncommon.
There we go.
One thing I gotta do, remember, is also...
I'm on tier 3.
So I gotta be a little extra careful.
But also, this guy is fragile.
This guy is literally...
He sneezes and he breaks.
Why?
Oh, gold gain.
I'm gonna go for the gold gain.
I'm not feeling anything else.
Get them bouncy bones.
Projectile speed is trash.
Not when you have all banana, all bone, all everything.
And it's all like...
You know?
Oh!
Oh my goodness gracious.
Try to get him up on top of me.
What's duration?
Oh, my attacks and projectiles.
Movement speed!
Movement speed, power- yeah, movement speed.
I'm gonna go with that.
Hello?
Oh!
B-free red!
Increase damage by 20% per 100 max HP.
Curse an enemy dealing 30% of their max HP.
Let's get that beef.
We're getting the beef.
Oh, thank you.
I'm gonna bow.
Level up.
Oh, shoot.
I was too good.
Now you need oats!
Earn money by...
That's all I do.
is move around.
Where's my money?
Okay, we're getting it.
The microwave!
Wait, what can I put in here?
Oh, I need...
Okay, I don't have a common item.
We're dodging and evading.
We're doing so good.
Was that axe good?
I don't remember.
I feel like the axe was pretty good, but I think I'm going
to get bone anyway.
Begun?
No, axe bad.
Oh, not for cow.
Okay.
Will do bone.
I need banana.
But I'm also trying to find the place.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I should probably... Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
I should start opening this.
Charge run.
Shua.
Speaking of.
Help!
Oh, that was close.
Crit chance.
Axe is one of the best?
Wait, people were saying Axe is not so good.
Where'd that big guy go?
He was like right behind me.
Oh, hello.
Ouch!
Oops.
I think... I think calcium is not my man I think we're just
not vibing I think we got different different tempos I'm
dead in that I am a ghost and he's dead in that he's a
skeleton like it's just really hard for our vibes to mesh
you know what I'm saying monkey let's go for monkey one more
chance we'll do them later like I don't have enough money
for an ogre yet so we want to keep getting that Katangamund,
welcome back.
Thank you!
This is hard for, you know, for us.
I think you might like calcium better on a different flatter
level.
What does that mean?
Oh, starting with a banana.
It's peak.
It's peak!
Hey, back off, buddy.
Oh, but I think XP again in the very beginning is really
good.
I think I'm gonna go with the XP.
Oh, less cliffy.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
Oh, we're already close.
Dang, I forgot how fast Skelly was.
It was so fast.
We're, like, super slow now.
Yippee!
We found it.
Banana rang Your rang Your banana rang Calcium spoils people
with speed I know I'm like Was the game always this slow?
Banana rang Ring ring ring ring ring
Banana fell I got this feeling So Oh, what the heck?
Where did you guys come from?
Oi!
Not the oats.
Oh my gosh, I accidentally...
No!
I didn't mean to...
My hand slipped and I pressed space and it picked up ours
thing!
I wanted ghost!
to this is fine next he tweeted me in the shirt in the shirt
why I saw oh my gosh Seymour I was literally talking about
it today it's so funny I'm proud of you for wearing your
shirt proud of you buddy proud of you I think I'm gonna go
for We need like better weapons right now.
I don't want to like run too far.
Oh my gosh, there's so many guys with their little crowns.
You can't all be kings.
It's not allowed.
Oh, that's right.
I can climb up walls.
Here I go.
Idiots.
Okay.
Wait, can I...
Oh, what if I want to go back down?
Wait, oh my god.
Wait, what if I want to...
Wait, wait, what if I want to...
Wait, oh shoot.
Wait, wait.
Ouch!
They're all coming at me.
It's frightening.
I'm too good at climbing.
I'm not so good at anything else.
I almost walked right into that guy.
Muay!
You have something good for me, you guys?
I'm gonna get the key.
NHP Riga Gen by 45.
Watch this.
Free!
Oh my gosh, wait, is it actually free?
I think it was actually free.
That one's activated.
There was a gold one I saw.
Okay.
Where is that guy?
Hold on.
Ah!
Where did the gold one go?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Ah!
No!
Ouch!
Oh my god!
Wait, please!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I'm gonna die here!
I'm gonna die!
Ouch!
I just need more weapon!
I need more weapon!
Swarm!
Okay, maybe I need to build back up to, uh, you know...
Uh... Maybe I need to build back up to, uh, Tier 3.
Hope you are well, Minto.
I'm up!
Wait!
We're struggling out here, everybody, but we're doing our
best.
Keep warming up.
Yeah, if we don't go all in at once, what's the point, you
know?
Revolver?
Sure.
Let's go, Revolver.
Maybe this is our lucky charm.
Maybe this is what I needed.
Am I gonna...
Ouch!
No, please!
It's over!
It's over for me!
Attack speed!
Or do I do live steal?
I think I'm gonna do attack speed.
Live steal?
Is live steal that good?
Is it really?
I guess I kind of need it, huh?
Ghost!
Why is it so hard to kill?
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone.
I haven't even hit that guy, the gold skelly for him to
leave.
Holy!
There's like a million and a half guys around me!
I'm too good at running away.
Oh shoot!
I need to watch where I'm running to.
Does anyone remember where the portal is?
I remember.
I need to get this guy off my booty!
Oh yeah it is on the map, you're right.
Oh shoot!
Pink revolver.
I'm not trying to dodge the pot!
Uh-oh.
Fall damage.
Ouch!
There's some.
There's one.
There's two.
I just don't want to get cornered, you know?
Ouch!
Oh.
We're jumping this way.
And we're jumping over here.
Everybody follow me this way.
I'll lead you to greatness.
And everything.
Yeah, I know.
If we could find a magnet, it would be huge.
Oh, I need, like, health so bad, too.
No!
Oh, my God.
I don't want to land right on him.
Again?
Oh, my gosh.
Holy...
Oh my god, it's overforce.
Everybody.
Wait, what if I just stand here?
Ah!
They can climb too!
No, Reca!
Try the Ogor.
Oh, I'm 4,000.
40,000.
40, 43,000.
40, 4,344.
They included a little extra zero in there.
For like flair.
You know, it's kind of like when you make a screen name.
And it's like my name is X0X.
Vampire's Last Kiss.
X0X.
Let's buy ourselves an ogre.
How exciting.
Wait, what else can we get under here?
Attraction tone.
Ooh, la-la.
Oh, what's this one?
Dragonfire.
Wait, should I get one of the epic weapons or epic items?
Because that'd be kind of fun.
Is it good?
Dragonfire.
It sounds good.
Ow, I bit my tongue.
Dragonfire.
fires okay okay oh I want a Santa hat okay let's just buy a
new person then it's all ogre it's all ogre all right come
here ogre what is Athena what do we need thorns tome to
level 9 default ogre okay I'm gonna do stage 2 oh that's not
what I meant to do let's just uh Oh yeah.
He comes walking in like he owns the place.
Is there anything around here?
Hey guys, I'm one of you.
What are you talking about?
What are we doing?
Where is everything?
The Chad walk.
Oh, these kind of suck.
Oh.
I'm gonna do movement speed.
Wait, what's my jump like?
I should have done an extra jump.
I'm an idiot.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I'm not alive, but I did learn.
I'm gonna do axe.
Because it would be nice to have three of them.
Three whole axes.
Or three whole asses.
Would you want an extra butt?
Where would the poop come from?
Which one?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
That was close.
Extra jump!
Wait, but the attack speed?
No?
That's why for me, the answer is no.
Yeah, they would have to like redo toilets and everything.
The projectile speed calls to me.
Are you claiming to own two bots?
I never said that.
Four of them!
Oh, the extra jump makes him go like crazy Insano style.
Oh wow, we already found it!
Let's go.
I wish...
I wish my axes...
would also be behind me.
Banana!
With damage.
Let's go banana.
Oh!
Born.
Brought to you by the mine behind And pee and sweat are the
same thing.
If I had an extra butt, where would the poop go?
Thank you.
Mintocrat, mintocraties.
Live steal though.
True.
Yeah, let's go with live steal.
Get him.
Yeah!
Wait, size tome!
I have a feeling that our ogre friend is a size, a queen.
Don't hurt me.
Baby, don't hurt me.
No more.
I want aura.
I'm thinking the cooldown.
What is love?
Baby, don't hurt me.
Don't hurt me.
No more.
What
is love?
Wait, I'm gonna go do this thing right here.
Moai!
We're gonna go to Moai first.
You ask Moai.
But nobody says...
No where, no who, no how, moai.
I want the chonkers.
Refresh?
You think so?
Okay, I will refresh.
It's my last, it's my only refresh.
What?
Wait!
Oh no, I want aura.
That's right.
More size.
Immediately rewarded?
It's like they always say.
Ask and you shall receive.
Oh my gosh.
Where'd that guy come from?
Is a gymsaw?
Is it good for...
For...
I mean, I guess damage is always good, right?
We already have ghosts, so...
Yeah.
How's it going, Minto?
How's it going, amazing?
How's it going for you?
What a yo pal, friend of mine!
Oh!
Bloody tome, honey.
Oh, I don't need it.
Chunk him!
Chunky!
Chunkers?
Ouch!
Did he get me again?
Oh my god, I'm so slow.
Holy cow.
Get that guy!
Stop him!
Yeah.
Yippee!
I didn't mean to use that.
Him hitting you slows you down a lot.
I could tell.
It's fun!
Wait, you look tough.
I'm taking a photo.
Nah, I didn't mean to use that.
Oats.
Let's do more.
Everything is size.
Let's do...
Size, size, size.
Everything is size.
Brother.
May I have some oats.
I could get everybody to have a bigger size.
But the size is, though.
Every size is a bit...
size um let's see what else can we find uh the what's it
called is right over yeah it's over here right there's other
stuff up here let's go check it out oh there it is okay just
kidding
oh my gosh that was so close lock we're still pretty early
in i'd say right right So I think luck is good.
Oh, hello.
I haven't gotten like...
Oh, I do have a lot of money.
Maldi cheese!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I haven't seen much, uh...
What's it called?
Bacon.
Plus one projectile!
Oh!
Finally back from a long week trip.
Missed you.
Welcome back!
Buck, buck.
What's this?
Oh, let's go.
More projectile!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oral.
Oh.
Lifesteal.
Oral.
Yeah.
Size.
Heck yeah, baby.
Oh, I missed it.
Thanks.
This is the Iran.
Size is good for close range.
I think I'm gonna do cooldown.
this time.
Because if we're fast, we can always...
Let's see what's up here.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, welcome.
Ah, the bush!
Stay away!
Oh, what the heck?
I don't remember these guys at all.
Oh, goodbye!
Never mind.
I was gonna get him, but, you know.
He's...
saw himself out.
Yeah, faster attacks mean even more projectiles.
Oh, more money!
Jeez!
Oh.
Sure, I'll take it.
What's the microwave do again?
Isn't it duplicate?
Choose an item.
Yeah, it's a clone.
Dupes an item.
Oh!
Wait, it costs an item.
Oh, well, I don't know what it ate, actually.
Eat one to clone another.
I hope it doesn't eat my cheese.
Oh, it ate my money shoes?
Oh, that's no biggie, I think.
More projectiles are bigger.
I'm more ideal at the moment.
Let's slide all the way down.
Oh, I see a free...
A freebie down there.
No think, just bong.
I'm going off pure instinct at the moment.
Alright, let's grab a bunch of these, and then we'll go back
and we'll do the...
We'll go back and we'll do the boss.
Oh, sure.
I'll take that.
Golden shoes, quantity is better.
Burns from the same tier, and cheese is common, so you're
good.
Cast blood magic upon hitting an enemy.
Could be huge.
Spock your shield!
What's our armor at?
Six.
Say six.
Whoa.
Excuse me.
I'm coming through.
Oh, perfect time to get this.
Wait, please come on.
Thank you.
Because we gotta go all the way back up here.
Ooh, that was moist.
Oh, epic axe!
Uh, where was it again?
Somewhere down here.
Swarmin coming.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
I'm gonna go with SARS.
The arrow on the map.
Oh yeah, yeah, thank you.
I knew where it was.
He's right down here.
Which is, what was it?
What made that noise?
Oh, ew.
This game looks fine.
It's quite fun.
Definitely recommend.
I think.
Give me some.
Oh, give me all that sweet cash.
Oh, yeah.
more size.
Actually.
I'm like, I'm flowing in riches.
Before we activate this, open.
The boss has been spawned.
Cool down.
My riches be great.
Oh.
We're sticking close.
Oh, there's two guys at once.
Really awesome.
I'm just running in circles.
Don't mind me.
Yay!
For the time, get the thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We'll do the cooldown.
Easy peasy.
Nah, nice.
More ghosts.
I'll do the aura.
We haven't leveled that one up in a while.
50% more damage while airborne.
Oh, guy.
A little more aura.
Alright.
Into the portal!
No final swarm.
Yes.
Everyone, behold, bewilder my power.
Yeah!
Ooh!
Jump height!
What the armor?
Wait, also we have the thorn thing, so I think the armor
would be better.
Time to start jumping all over the place.
What's the eggs for?
I can't remember.
Oh no!
Oh, it's these things.
I don't quite care so much.
They can get lost for all I care.
They're not my children.
Wait, what happened to that one?
Cool.
More jumps!
Wait, but I did do that over the attack speed.
Maybe it was a mistake.
Who knows?
Increase evasion.
Yeah, that kind of hurt a little bit.
Honestly, I can't tell at all what's happening.
Everything is, like, happening at once.
You know what I mean?
It's, like, all so much going on in the world.
I'm healing.
Okay, I'm good now.
Let's go find ourselves a portal.
Yeah, lots of chaos.
I can't see anything.
There's too many...
There's so many axes.
How do I have 5.2 axes?
Or 3.2 banana racks.
Yeah, speaking of axe, we're gonna get another one.
Shall we multiply our cheese?
More cheese.
I'm glad you're having fun, meantime.
I'm always having fun.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye health pack.
He's done.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
We'll find a...
a magnet.
No, come back!
I'm gonna kill you.
Where'd he go?
Did I get all my money?
Did he already despawn?
It's so lame.
Why?
Reflect any incoming damage back to the attacker and gain a
short invulnerability.
You can use multiple times.
I know.
but I needed to get out of there.
Oh, shoot.
Why are you so fast?
You're humongous.
Leave me alone, please.
More booger.
Oh, I ate one.
More projectile.
Evade!
Ouch.
I'm trying to get that lightning bolt, but he's kind of
camping it.
Wait, what did that do?
Yeah!
Oh, I can't see anything.
I cannot see anything right now.
There's too much...
There's too much happening!
There's...
Everything is happening in the world!
Over-stimulated!
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot!
I'm trying to get out!
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I can't stand there.
Oh, what the hell?
Am I back at the children?
Or did they just run all-
There we go.
Nimmy Reigns!
Thank you so much for the thank you, dude!
If you guys like Mega Bonk, I think it's so fun.
Oh, epic aura.
Size.
Zinnable, thank you, Spink.
Thank you, Dargo, thank you.
T, Covenant Union, thank you.
Ducky, thank you.
Rock, rubber, rubber, thank you.
Jay, thank you.
Now I'll take you.
Thank you, thank you.
Mega Bonk is a great time indeed.
I'm still learning the game, but I'm having so much fun.
The bow, thank you.
Size.
Bigger.
Bigger, bigger.
I wanted to watch Nimmy play that new game.
The thing that's not the Sims.
Bill, thank you.
My neff, thank you.
Jay Lakon, thank you.
It's a good one, thank you.
Bickler.
Beggar.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh.
Reflect.
I'm rubber and you're a glue.
Whatever you say, bounces off of me and sticks to you.
Bozo.
Oh my god.
More jumps.
No!
What game is...
I mean, talking about...
Oh, the one that's like the Sims.
It's...
What's it called?
Like, Paralives or something?
Right?
Yeah, Paralives.
And, like...
It's another life simulation thing.
It was going so well.
Ew, wise!
But it seems like the Sims?
But not quite.
Curse of Quiet.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I'm a 3,272 in a 2.
It's an early access, but then we lacked it.
They did pretty good with those axes.
I kind of want to unlock more people you know complete two
challenges by weapon wireless dagger like who should I aim
for bush oh yeah I did defeat him but I gotta buy the sniper
rifle how do I get that wait that's
a shotgun is that there it is get the precision tone Do I
even have that?
Yes.
We gotta do a precision tone run, everybody.
Chance to deal critical damage.
That's always a plus.
I want the bush.
Birdo!
What are you doing in the game?
But yeah, who's your favorite character?
Who do you think I should try working for as a playable
character?
Just found out about you from Fandom 8!
Oh my gosh, welcome!
Thank you so much for dropping by!
Thank you, thank you!
Monkey is my favorite.
You like a ninja?
Ninja?
Whoa, complete desert tier 1.
Okay, I think I'm quite far from there.
Vlad, desert tier 2!
Okay, I think we're a little...
Kill Spooky Steve.
Who the heck is that?
Is there a Minto in this game?
Actually, yes.
You can get Ghost.
Use a microwave to duplicate Ice Crystal three times in a
row.
Hmm.
I don't even know Ice Crystal.
I don't even know if I have that.
Noel is good.
For now, let's go for Bush.
we will try and get the sniper rifle so we got to get our
precision tome to what was it nine wait oh sniper rifle
that's right that's what I wanted to go to 10 10 10 10 10 10
10 okay I'll play
I kind of want to play Chad I feel like he was my best runs
was Chad you know over the over over monka yeah bush is an
acquired taste is it now I'm curious how he works let's go
chat let's chat it up I'll even try tier 3 wait what is a
challenge fragile die upon taking any damage only have 14
minutes to win 12 minutes Kill all bosses Oh shit too Kill
all bosses
Fragile is easier on Berto Got it
I mean we could always do like this one And try Definitely
not gonna do Or we could do the speed runner We'll do it
We'll try Why not?
You know what?
Tier 2 speed runner We'll try.
It's just a little bit less time.
I love this song.
What do you mean I can't... Oh, I can't afford it, you're
right.
Die?
And we're close to the...
There it is, right down there.
Check this out.
Luck tome!
Wait, okay.
Everybody ever met- wait.
I wanted the precision tome, but...
Oh, wait.
This is awkward, isn't it?
Bobo!
I still don't have it.
RNG is not the kind.
But I did find a white Bobo.
So if I get a white teal ghost Bobo, it would be even more
me, though.
Can you give me a good RNG blessing?
REN!
Good luck with your Bobo hunt!
Good luck!
Good.
Literal aura farming.
Whoa!
I kind of want to save up for mirror.
This is the character that is actually me, though.
Actually me.
Reflection on him?
More luck.
Okay.
I gotta...
Not luck again.
Oh.
I almost went the crit chance.
I think I'm gonna go with it.
Watch this.
Why is he on his knees?
Luckily, that one guy is like right next to us, right?
The shady man.
So we can just go back and find him easily.
Not projectile speed.
I'll go with aura.
Oh, oops.
I forgot I'm saving that money.
Oh, I care.
I'll make lots of money.
Oh, 14% damage to Elites.
Wait, that's pretty good because...
Because...
Because they have more HP?
No, I did the time.
I'm a dummy.
But it is good.
It's an elite.
It's elite.
Styling on that rock.
Just check that out.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
Ouch.
Ha, you guys are stupid and follow me.
Oop.
A banana.
Let's just banana it up.
Why am I so fragile?
No, come back, please.
Yay!
Go down here.
Oh, another shady guy.
Yeah, we gotta save money for the shady guy.
Cowards.
Boost movement speed upon taking damage.
Also gain 5% movement speed.
And cheese!
All of these are good!
Because I'm shirtless.
Nice.
Seize?
Okay.
We still, we can get more money.
Yeah, spend money to make money, everybody.
That's the philosophy.
Oh, gosh.
Oh my god, you guys are so fast.
I know you're my biggest fans, but please.
Wait, would...
You can just be good so that we can have a better
defense?
Kind of no.
Okay, money spent.
What's up to?
The money will come.
It's like a fortune cookie.
You know, when you read it and it says like, the money will
come.
It's good.
XP Tome.
We are!
Only level 5, so let's do XP.
Why do they keep pushing that poor box around?
Free box!
I mean, chest.
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Goodness gracious!
Why are you guys so strong?
It's disgusting.
Disgusting greed.
What do you have?
Clover!
Okay, we gotta go back.
Oh, there's another free one.
Ghost.
Okay, we gotta go back to our buddy-o-pal friend of mine.
Certain somebody that's with a red hat.
Oh, okay.
After a week of Vodgang, it's good to see live, Vinky.
Tuna!
Where are you at?
Where have you been?
Where were you?
I'm just kidding.
Okay, I can't take another tome because I'm trying to get
the precision tome.
So let's do a banana rung.
Oh, there's a thing over here I missed.
Oh, heck yeah.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
More XP?
Damage.
More banana.
Are you done yet?
Ouch!
Run away, run away, run away, run.
Where was that guy?
With the hat anyway.
Oh, there he is.
I'm coming for you, buddy.
I got him.
saved up.
This is my life savings.
I'm giving it all to you.
Upon taking damage, that would kill you freeze time.
Breaks after one use.
Now that is really cool, but I feel like Mirror might be
better, no?
Every tone but the one we want.
I know.
Zawarudo!
Mirror, mirror, Why do you remember?
Time stop is good.
I guess that's true.
Yeah, I'm only...
I'm going one or three.
I just can't decide which one.
Mirror is more consistent.
That is what...
I know, it's only one time use, so it's kind of like...
Is it going to be that great?
Oh my gosh.
Stop pushing that box.
I can't get my earnings right now.
I have to run for it.
Guys, I think this is it for me.
I think I'm trapped.
Oh, please!
The music is slow and sad!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, nice, reflect.
Oh my god.
It's Megabog slow sad version.
What is a reverse?
What's the word?
Nightcore.
You know how there's those videos that are just like this
song, but you hear it from the other room?
Daycore?
I didn't get at all what I wanted to happen.
So let's try again.
I think with just aura and banana, it's pretty tough, you
know what I mean?
We gotta get lucky with, like, getting something.
Some good weapons.
Yeah, bad RNG for sure.
Precision time!
16% duration.
This time you'll do it.
Thank you for believing in me.
I'm gonna try it.
Let's see if we can get some cash.
What's this over here?
Exclamation point.
Oh, it's a magnet.
Oh, there's some shady guys over here.
And the more I think I saw...
Oh, ouch.
Rude.
So rude.
Yeah, more XP, please.
I think I can only go with shield.
Oh, we found it already.
Alrighty, nice.
Yippee!
Let's go with...
Giant Fork!
Oh, spaghetti!
Wait, that's crazy!
Wait, oh my gosh.
Do I save up for it?
Oh, crits have a 14% chance to become mega crits.
Save.
Oh, oh.
Phew.
That scared me.
I will go for the luck.
I'm trying to decide what kind of like weapon I want to, you
know.
Okay, nice.
Some more cash.
Mega crits are nice.
I bet.
I bet they're crazy.
Hey, give me money.
Give me money.
Oh!
Or that?
Chaining or piercing attacks like lightning, bow, bone, burn
down an enemy.
Yeah, I think bone would be really good, huh?
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Revolver too?
Well, we can do a revolver and we can work...
Try for a revolver, try for bone.
Oh my god.
Ooh, oh, hey, hey!
Let me get my war...
Please!
You guys are being so greedy!
Does this count?
I was like a...
Or...
I don't remember if I've ever used the lightning staff
before.
Always Nana.
It didn't work so good for us last time though.
I'm worried about it.
Wow.
I mean, I could always refresh.
I could always refresh and try for bone.
You did prick duration.
Ooh.
Alright, we're gonna start working up our precision...
Ouch!
You landed right on my head!
Our precision tome so that we can, uh...
get that to level 10 because then we get to unlock the new
stuff so projectile count wait does a revolver and the
electricity count as projectiles
yeah okay oh they're new they're new little guys different
guys i could never get them though oh there's a moai down
here let's explore a little over here and such yes thank you
All right, we'll save that for later.
Oh, nice crit.
Nice crit.
Very nice.
Standing still heals you.
That's so risky.
It's too risky.
Key.
Wait, why are you guys...
Why were you yellow?
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
We'll do the damage to elites.
I'm gonna go with the quantity again.
Let's get the stuff over here.
I'm gonna magnet.
Oh, we can go get the fork now!
We can go get the fork.
Curse an enemy.
Magnet and then...
Oh, life steal.
I'm gonna do the life steal.
Oh nice lightning staff.
I know I need to do my precision more but Okay, so far not
so bad
Let's go get the fork Staying alive That's like Find the
frogs Wait I found frogs I When the heck did I do that?
Mirror raid?
Hello!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Welcome to Mega Bank!
Mega, Mega Bank!
I'm trying right now to unlock some more items, so we're
doing, like, a bit of a...
A bit of a specific build.
Where's our little guy at?
We're gonna go make some shady dealings at the moment.
Wait, how did you get all the way over there?
Wait, how did you do that?
That's not plausible, right?
Yeah!
Just teleported, you cheater.
Oh my gosh, they knocked over that entire pillar.
Okay, so too, thank you!
Paperbacks, thank you, Dwargo, thank you!
Thank you.
The passive AoE killed frogs.
Let's go!
You gotta get level 10 in six minutes.
And also...
Well, we're on...
We could go to the second tier too, right?
She said we should just remain friends.
Roast me.
I deserve it.
What?
Why would we roast you?
Frog for rubber, thank you.
Swarming coming.
Let's go grab the...
Ow, grab these chests over here.
Quantity.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
We're okay.
Fish.
Another cursed doll!
There's a microwave.
I don't know what I can...
I don't know what I could microwave.
tech extra gold when taking damage well that kind of stinks
for sure i'll take it
maybe we um maybe we activate the boss i gotta get more x
wait there was a suck over here we can suck And we can get
more XP.
Because we're kind of...
There's some guys we're killing, like, pretty far away.
So we want to get them.
The mega crit is kind of going crazy.
I wish it would give me...
More...
What's the word?
More stuff for my...
For my other tome, please!
Yeah, more precision tome.
There it is.
Precision tome.
Revolver.
Uh, aura.
Okay.
Yeah, I guess we could refer for us.
I forgot about that.
It's okay though.
It's okay.
We made some progress.
That was good.
It was good stuff.
Sure.
I'm just trying to get some stuff now.
Phantom Shroud!
My evasion is not...
strong suit I think but that's okay let's get some or close
to a new level yes ah I'm gonna do the quantity though
hmm oh okay hello oh I could use another another sucker the
bush I'm more I'm working towards you, mister!
I'm trying!
Did I get this Moai?
Yes, I did.
If I go down there...
Oh, I can get back up through here.
More evasion, yeah, we'll take it.
More damage, we'll take it.
I really need...
More XP though.
Like crazy levels.
the build so far so far yeah we're like not getting swarmed
like you know where i you know what i'm gonna just do this
guy summon the challenge
okay i spoke too soon
i think we need it though for the xp you know Give me that
for the XP.
We'll do a little limbo.
He gets swarmed.
More quantity.
And check this out.
Yeah!
I'm raging against the machine!
Oh, that guy's huge.
No, I think he actually was just really tall.
Oh!
Lightning stuff.
Whoa!
Epic lightning stuff!
Qua...
Legendary aura!
Where the heck is my...
Okay.
I almost want to refresh.
The luck is paying off.
Yeah, baby!
Next I did for karaoke.
That's okay.
This is fine, I guess.
Thundermades.
Clap their cheeks so hard, it generates lightning.
More lightning.
Precision Tom!
Okay, it's time to summon the boss.
Oh, oh.
Not you, stupid chunk'em.
Chunk'em!
Oh.
He's just...
What are you standing there for, dummy?
Idiot.
Holy cow.
We took him out so fast.
Sure.
Alright.
Let's go.
Get this guy.
Where's this guy?
Lil Bark!
His bark is little, but his bite is massive.
It's also kind of fast.
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Level 6, 3 to go.
Wait, no, we didn't know we gotta get to level 10!
Ah, I can't see!
Oh my gosh!
Ouch, ouch again.
It's okay, uh, there's like hearts around here or something.
Oh, hello.
I don't know when I...
Yeah, free box.
What?
Upon taking damage, send out an electric shock.
I'm like, I'm all electricity, man.
It's so strange.
How did it happen like this?
I don't know at all.
Yay!
Oh!
Two epics and one!
It was my life.
luck that good?
You just love Denki.
Yeah!
Dempa, dempa.
The revolver?
Yeah, because the crit damage is insane, actually.
A rare quantity.
More.
Another Amini cursed dolls.
I have three of them.
Wait, can I not get any more items?
I think about it.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I gotta leave.
We gotta get out of here.
Enter the portal.
We could get more items, but I want to get...
I don't know.
I feel...
Oh, okay.
Nobody put baby in the corner.
Why are the vibes off?
Honestly, I'm like, how did I survive some of these other
levels?
How did I do it?
guy down there we're gonna go to him for sure
only four minutes i know it's i'm kind of nervous i'm kind
of nervous old game movement speed projectile speed speed or
how fast maybe how fast i move would be better i think or
how we yeah i think how fast i move is gonna be more all
right let's go get this guy and then Let's go hunt for the
thing.
Because I think he's a...
He's a good...
More XP, please.
I don't know if we'll get the...
I don't know if we'll survive...
Or get the...
Unlock the thing that we needed.
Oh!
Beefy ring!
It's probably pretty good right now.
Maybe cast blood magic upon hitting an enemy damaging nearby
enemies and healing.
Oh healing is kind of nice They're all epic, so it's like
hard to decide Slurp is good Okay You know getting hitting
more enemies is always a plus right All right How do I open
the map again like what button is that?
M.
That makes sense.
No, it's not.
Hit escape and there's a...
Okay, thank you.
I just want to make sure...
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm going to focus on breaking pots as well.
Oh!
It's painful.
to have to do the precision tome instead of the epic
lightning stuff.
It's absolutely painful.
What do you got?
Increased damage by 2.5% when opening a chest.
It's kind of cool.
I do open a lot of chests.
Okay.
I got that rage.
Credit card seems good.
It's kind of weak this late.
I guess that's true too.
We could...
We have Phantom Shroud.
We could like...
It could stack.
One is probably best this late.
That's what I'm thinking.
Let's just go with it.
Alright.
More!
XP, please.
Chest and Spectrum and Phantom.
Yes.
Jump height.
Alright, we're looking for the red winds.
The red winds.
Chunk them again?
I'm so bored of you.
Rude?
What do you got?
It's a water dough, my friend.
be good this time.
So I don't know if it might be good this time so that I can
get more stuff.
I'm gonna get it.
Hey!
That was a cheap shot, buddy.
You know that I was making a deal, okay?
Ouch!
Uh-oh.
I tried moving.
I did.
I need a Oh,
the oats.
I know.
It always has bad luck for me.
It spells bad luck.
Yeah!
Yes.
Drag it in, baby.
Drag it in.
No!
Ha!
Did I just say swarm?
Do I have a swarm?
Where am I coming?!
Oh my god!
Whoop!
Where's the tomb?!
I have 47 seconds left?
It doesn't matter as long as I get the tomb!
Ah!
Zawato just kicked in?
Anyway.
I'm leaving.
Get me out of this hellscape.
There goes Zawato.
It was used for a good cause.
Wait, Chunkum is still alive.
Oh my god.
I gotta up some of my other things, like my revol- like the
damage, you know?
So, it's your revolver.
There is no escape, only Chunkum.
Oh, we found it!
We found it!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Wait!
My health is full!
What happened?
Oh, it was the...
Oh, that's right.
It was the time.
The time limit!
We were so close.
We did get something at least.
One unlock.
That was such a...
That was such a good run.
I want the hat.
We had such a good...
been going.
Can you go to your unlockables?
Curious is what you need for your fourth weapon in Tome
Slot.
My web weapon?
What fourth weapon?
This one?
The sluddy rocket?
Oh, we need to use Clank some more.
Unlockable.
Yeah, I am unlocks.
Go to the shop and hover over the tome and weapons.
Oh, the shop?
Wait.
Huh?
Sorry, wrong thingy.
He means shop, though.
I was just in the shop.
This one?
40 quests?
I am in the shop!
This is literally called shop!
Click the other weapon that's blacked out.
This one?
The banish?
Huh?
Guys are confusing me!
Oh wait, we can earn- we gotta- This is what I'm talking
about!
You gotta spend money?
Money?
To earn money!
Refresh level up offers.
Whoa!
Sorry, never mind, it doesn't show.
Everybody's confusing me.
Everybody's acting like I'm stupid.
I think chat is confused.
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
But I will buy a few of these.
Yeah, let's make some more money.
Let's make some more money.
But for quests, let's see what we can do.
What's something that we're close to, you know?
Hmm.
Oh, this is just hats.
Thorns, a tome.
Thorns tome.
Complete two challenges.
We're never getting that guy.
Uh...
Who the heck is spooky, Steve?
I have never seen that guy before in my afterlife.
Freeze with the ice cube.
Yeah, I don't have this unlocked.
I tried getting...
We can get...
We'll try and get...
What was it?
I was trying to get Bush.
You gotta get the precision tome to level 10.
That's what we were aiming for last time.
But I guess because I had the...
I was trying to kill two birds with one stone.
I was trying to do that.
Plus also the speed run.
So I could get like a challenge, you know, but I was greedy.
I was greedy.
Um, agility tome to level five.
Kill 100 cactus enemies.
I'm not, I don't know why I get to the desert.
Hmm.
Let's see.
Oh, complete 45 quests.
We'll get two silver for that.
Oh, complete 40 quests.
We'll get silver for that.
To get to the desert, you need to kill the final boss.
So we do need to do a tier 3 craziness, huh?
Should we try?
Maybe with... Okay.
Mega chat is pretty good.
If I use him...
Similar build as before.
But no challenge.
I get rid of it.
But we do tier 3.
Sir Umphi though?
What about him?
He's so slow.
Wait, you don't need to beat the final boss to unlock the
desert.
Look at desert, wouldn't you?
There is no desert.
Oh, here!
Wait, this is the desert, I assume.
Teleport to the second stage on Forest Tier 2 is...
Just kidding, we're playing as Clank!
Never mind!
Wait, as calcium on desert- okay.
Okay.
Let's go!
What does- this guy has the revolver, right?
Or am I crazy?
Little-little-little-little-little-little-little-little-little
Oh, that's not what I meant to do!
We'll- Okay.
What have we killed two birds?
one stone again what if we do that what if we do the same
thing that we did before you know we get the precision tone
and we okay i'm gonna do get the xp tone then because then
you know we can have crazy
i wish we could get my fork back i loved having that guy I'm
gonna get the I'm gonna do the wrong
Two my eyes Hot dog I think I ran into that guy though More
Why More why
More cash
Wow Wow
Jump height.
Crit chance?
I know.
I hope RNG is kind to me too.
Crit chance?
I'm listening to you guys.
Oh!
I don't want to get into their tone just in case.
You know?
At the moment.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Wow!
Whee!
Slurp!
We'd be slurping up in here?
I could really use a precision tone right now though.
Oh, if only someone could just deliver me a precision tone,
that sure would be the bee's knees.
I guess a banana rang.
I know I did kind of want to grab the luck tone, but we got
the luck tone.
Lucky Clover too.
Re-roll.
Yeah.
Give me the luck tome again.
Maybe I should grab it so that I can have a better time.
Banana though.
I know.
It pains me.
Luck or more gun.
I'm going to go for luck.
Maybe the game will understand what I'm trying to do.
And luckily, Give me...
Um...
What I need.
Oh!
Another cursed dog.
You can do it!
Show em!
Muay!
Mito!
Thank you, Kamendachi.
Muay!
Ouch!
Get cursed.
I curse thee, I cast.
Am I going the right way?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, scary.
Okay, yeah, we gotta explore.
Oh, we gotta explore this away.
Ouch.
I could really use another weapon, though.
Okay.
No!
I have to pick something.
Oh yeah, I can skip!
Actually, I'm gonna banish.
Wait, Spanish?
I'm gonna banish the evasion tome.
That way, we don't get another tome.
You know?
I really want bones.
RNG is not...
Oh, we found it!
We found it, we found it.
Nalasia?
Ow!
Ouch!
Mawai!
Please grant me a fork so I can eat!
Let's go for the key.
I like the key.
Because I like opening things.
It's exciting and there's a little bit of gotcha.
I know, not the ult again.
Nice stinking.
What is it down there?
I guess so?
Push-a!
Oh.
Precision to- Wow.
Oops, all tomes.
Oh my gosh, imagine if we didn't have the precision tome in
there.
Yippee!
Fear is nice, but clank is frail.
Oh!
Ow!
Ooh, that was a close one.
Yeah, it was a close one.
I'll really go for some bones right now.
You know what's on my list?
Bone.
I don't think we're...
I'm afraid we're not going to survive this, you guys.
I'm afraid we're not going to survive this swarm.
I'm afraid.
We still got to beat the Stone Golem.
That guy is still not even dead.
Where is he?
I lost sight of him.
He doesn't even know where he is.
There he is.
Oh my gosh.
Wait!
Whop!
She's so close to death, too.
Stay frosty.
Thank you.
Oh.
What does the little skull thing do again?
I don't remember.
I walked past it, and I couldn't tell.
Our chunker is good.
Fear!
Oh, difficulty in my knee.
Okay.
Yeah, I need a bit more AOE damage clear for swarms.
I know, right?
Ah, scat!
Thank you guys.
Chunker's bad.
I'll do more luck then.
Holy cow.
Holy cow!
Oh, that was so close.
I have to go!
Wait, no, precision tome, sorry.
I really need more weapons, but...
I on the prize as well.
Well, the prize can't happen.
if I die, so...
I'm stuck!
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep!
Hey!
Quit appearing!
It's unfair.
I'm going in circles and collecting my... my loot.
Oh, we killed them, but where is...
Lightning staff!
Let's grab that again.
We killed them somewhere.
There he is.
Nice.
Fun?
Da!
Ghost!
Bob!
Ouch!
Why?
Wait, this guy's been here the whole time.
I hate you.
XP, Tony.
Kill everybody here!
Ah!
Guys, we found the uh...
We found it.
Oh, lucky us.
I guess we have to do a banana ring, huh?
It really wants us to get the banana ring.
I wish I could have gotten the projectile tone.
Extra projectile.
Nana for luck.
I'm like, do I...
I can't decide between XP or lightning.
We can do...
We'll do more lightning here.
Oh, more lightning here.
Oh, my gosh.
Where is my stuff for the precision?
Oh, please.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, we gotta go for the precision.
Unfortunately.
Again, precision.
It's important.
For the...
Whoa!
Please!
Let's grab some of these chests over here.
Sure.
Let's grab this one.
Uh-oh.
Banana rang.
Banana, banana, banana!
Banana!
You bastard!
Tactical retreat?
Ouch!
Guys, I'm...
I'm not doing so hot today!
I'm not doing so hot today at all!
We'll try doing the same thing we did before, just with
better luck and stuff.
I kind of want the XP gain.
We'll do jump, jump later.
Actually, give me one second.
I'm going to go grab some more water.
I'll be right back.
Okie dokie.
Crit damage!
I
don't like any of these.
Unlock run struggles.
I know.
My goodness.
Get the wrench?
Yeah, seems like the probably the...
quick, the quick, what's it called?
Unlock up the thing.
Go on to the tome!
We needed that last time, honestly.
We'll do it this time.
Die, die, and give me your money.
I rob you, I rob you of all your possessions and all of your
worth.
Maybe you haven't succeeded in this run, but you sure
succeeded in making me feel a bit better while I'm still
sick.
Run, feel better!
Quantity two.
Moe problems.
It's true.
It's another curse, doll.
It's so true.
Moe money.
Moe problems!
after me because I'm such a sexy robot with tons of cash.
Wait, get that guy, get this guy.
Kill that guy.
Quantity.
Nice.
Bone!
I've got a bone to pick with you!
Game.
What's with this luck, huh?
Oh, wait, I unlocked something over there.
My bad.
I feel like it's been forever since I've seen the bone.
I got so excited.
I just picked it.
Not beer.
Might as well take it.
It's meant for me.
Oh, I think I meant to do the quantity tone, but that's
okay.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Just say I got a small retro...
Oh, I went to a small retro game con.
cause peace walker mix oh you got that i'll let you know how
it is yes wait is that the one where like them in the uh in
the what's it called in the uh onsen together cheers it's a
bureau clock baby uh oh i need to refresh we'll do the
revolver Oh, there's a free one over here.
Freebie!
That single goblin got nuked.
Oh, unstable transfusion threat, plus 35 chance to apply a
stack of bloodmark.
Oh, okay.
I'm stuck on a rock.
Okay, we need to explore this area anyway.
Stone golem, you're already here!
Welcome!
Welcome in, welcome in!
Ow!
Big quantity.
Kind of?
Key!
I love it!
I love the key.
Okay, I don't think...
Actually, wait, where am I?
I'm trapped.
I wish I were the monkey right now.
Actually, I'm actually trapped.
Holy cow!
That took me out.
Oh wait, I passed right by the MOI!
Holy cow!
Wait, we killed that guy.
Where did he go?
Um, we'll do the gym size.
Where did his- where did he die?
Oh, over there.
More beer!
I'm gonna be so litty, baby.
Cool.
I will also get another thing.
Sure.
Okay, I think it's on the other side of this little island,
so we gotta go this way.
Quantity!
Come on!
Wait, have we even gotten the precision to him at all?
Oh, I think we're so screwed.
No!
We're screwed.
We're screwed for real.
Oh, yes, cheese.
Cheese, my beloved.
Well, there it is.
Right as I'm about to die.
I hate this game.
I hate this game!
We got it, though.
I just have to regen health like craziness at the moment.
I'll just keep opening stuff, opening for a miracle.
and does damage at the same time.
If I get it, I'll get it.
If I get it, I'll take it.
At this point, I'm kind of desperate.
This guy is so...
He's a little baby.
He's a little...
He hurts a little.
Oh, it's behind me.
It's behind me?
More bone.
I like the lightning staff.
But
I guess it's able to do the Aegis.
More projectile.
Gotta go fast.
Wait, I want this.
Thank you.
Um, this way.
Where is it?
Over here?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Praying for fork.
Give him me to Sista.
What was it?
What was the other tome I was trying to get?
I wish I could just...
This is so...
This is so unlucky.
We're getting such unlucky here.
Yeah, I'm going to go grab that heart for sure.
I don't know how we made it out of there.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't know how we made it out.
There's another heart down there.
A little bit of...
What'd you drop?
Oh!
Yippee!
Precision tome.
Please.
This robot cowboy is busted as hell if you go for attack,
quantity, crit, life, stuos.
Hey.
Like, you got this, I think?
Precision tome?
Aegis!
Wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee?
I kind of want the luck tome, but...
I kind of want lifesteal, too.
I feel like I need it.
So we'll go for a revolver.
We'll go for Aegis.
We'll go...
Oh.
Uh...
Hmm...
Size...
The size...
Doesn't quite help us here, does it?
Skipper?
Let's banish...
Knockback.
Precision!
Though, if I do get live steal, I will take it.
Oh!
Yoink!
Summon the challenge.
No, thank you.
Don't tell me what to do.
Where are we?
Oh, we're not that far from them.
We're not as far as I thought we were from them.
Swarm incoming!
Oh my gosh, they're just pushing around this block.
Eat this.
Wee.
Be gone with the...
Okay, so far, we're doing alright.
I said, as we started then, got to be alright.
In fact, doing not so good.
I'm gonna go down here.
I'm gonna grab this chest.
The chest open.
Is that what I heard?
But where?
Where did the chest open?
Oh, I see it!
It won't escape from me, my little freebie.
A lot she's bonking.
Wait, on the rock.
No wonder I didn't see it.
Precision?
Okay, we gotta go summon the boss now.
Ah!
Not you!
This guy- Whoa!
Power gloves!
percent chance upon hitting an enemy to create a giant blast
what whoa oh
we can summon them both i guess where is uh
maybe that was kind of stupid but who cares
what the size the skull on the map oh yeah he's over there
okay we're headed to here
to over here.
I gotta summon both at the same time.
Kind of stinky.
But it's gotta be done.
It's gotta be done.
Oh, we got him anyway.
Little idiot.
Why are you summoning your trees in the air, huh?
Summon your trees.
Put your trees in the air.
Like you just don't care are your trees in the air wave
around a bear
so far this is okay oh nice live steal we got it oh my god
oh my god nice nice rare bone precision
all right let's all let's go on through i could keep going
but i'm just gonna enter the portal it's okay it's okay
everybody it's fine oh we got the desert this is what we
wanted okay that's one thing down that's one goal down
yeah Shady, man.
You have a fork for me?
Because I am hungry.
Uh-oh.
I don't want oats.
Let's get some moldy cheese.
The oats of death.
The oats are the curse upon me.
Curse you with your oats.
Oh, I see a MOI.
Let's grab that.
Um, we'll do a more lifesteal.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I see two MOI.
How exciting.
Oats and curry.
No!
Um, evasion.
We'll do go with...
We'll just do that.
I think I already had the ring anyway, so...
No, I didn't.
I'm a liar.
I'm a liar!
Yeah, that's about it.
Ranch?
The juice is good.
Yeah, but I'm always moving.
I'm always moving.
Aren't... Oh, it's good with lifesteal.
Oh, wait, are they?
Yeah, I don't stand still enough.
I'll go with the wrench.
I really don't stand still enough.
I'm too scared.
Oh, I think this one was free.
Cool.
I guess I gotta be jumping more.
Oh, I'll take that.
Thank you.
Meow.
Oh, another more eye.
Craziness.
I guess we'll do Oats then, right?
Because ABJ will be jumping.
Oh.
Oh, it wasn't free.
I was looking at my thing, I guess.
Yeah.
I think...
Ouch.
We gotta find...
Oh, what am I...
Oh, I was stuck on a tree that I could not even see.
Nice.
Whoa.
Wow, this luck is crazy.
Whoa, I guess we'll do the bone.
Epic bone.
Nice.
Nice epic bone.
Oh, but the quantity.
I kind of want an epic bone.
It's so hard to resist when things are really good in an
army.
Again.
All right, we got to start going this way.
We are in search of...
Oh, I see a golden.
Hello, mister.
Welcome back.
Let's go through here.
And open that.
It's not that I don't like shrines.
It's that I don't find myself able to stop for long enough.
Like, especially...
Oh, hello.
Especially for...
I mean, maybe this is now charging them faster, but...
It's just tough.
I'm gonna go with the damage.
Especially when you have a boss guy like this coming at you.
You know.
Where'd he go?
He's getting eaten away by the cheese.
Excuse me, I'm trying to find where the place is.
Ooh.
Cha-cha!
Whoa!
Legendary Bloody Toad.
Hope you had a fun long weekend.
Hope you watched you play on non-work one day.
I hope you did too!
How wrong!
Thank you for this over time!
Game gives you free sports card when you want milk.
I know, right?
Please, I'm so thirsty.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, thank goodness, life steal.
Wait!
Ouch!
Not good!
This one's golden.
I can try.
I can try for it.
But I'm nervous.
The projectile count!
Holy cow!
Okay,
uh, he died and I'm not quite sure where...
Oh, Jesus.
More, more, more, more!
I actually have no idea, and we also need to find the thing
still.
It was up on a ledge, was it?
I don't see it at all.
I wish I could get a fork.
Wait, there's a...
There's a...
Oh, I see it!
Also, there is a...
What's it called that way?
Oh, I think I need to go back up.
Oopsie.
Oh, sheesh.
Ouch.
Oh, just kidding.
How do I get up there?
But the magnet is over there, too.
Yeah, the magnet is where I want to...
What I want as well.
How do I get up there?
Uh-oh.
You have to go all the way around?
This is so lame.
It's fine.
We need to explore this area anyway either.
Either way.
Precision toad!
Wait.
Movement fast.
Oh.
See ya!
Bye!
Let me in!
Guys, I actually have no idea how to get over there.
I swear!
I'm trying to get over there and I have no clue!
I see...
Oh my gosh.
I see... Okay, okay, I think we made it.
I still haven't found the thing though.
I wish I could be the monkey and climb up the walls, but
unfortunately...
I really need the magnet though, 100% so I'm okay with going
all the way back over here.
in the magnet we can uh probably hopefully get enough to
maybe
please please let me live please let me live magnet please
let me live please please just one more one more i
completed 40 quests oh my god we did it we did it
Oh!
Let's keep going.
More lifesteal.
Why not?
More everything.
More everything!
Yeah, get the bloody Tome 10.
Okay, let's do that next.
And if I could, if I could, if I could, get out of here!
Oh, I did find it, apparently.
Somehow.
I don't know when I did that, but I did find it, apparently.
I got started spending my money.
I'm rich, baby.
Woo, wings were those.
Get out of my way.
Oh, I see it.
Okay.
Let's go summon a guy.
Oh.
Chonkum!
I keep saying let's go summon, and it's how...
You happen every time.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Where'd it go?
Wait.
I actually have no idea where it's at, so it's kind of
funny.
Um, I can't really look at the map at the moment.
Oh, it's back that way.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Back into the fray.
I passed it.
Because I didn't see it at all.
Oopsie.
Oh!
Uh...
Oh, I see it!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Whoop!
Um, I don't want to summon, but we must.
This is so insane.
Huge money.
I'm actually gonna get the revolver up more a little bit.
oh my gosh we have two bosses at once and a chest that I
want to open with my huge cash precision more okay I'm
working on like 500 million things I've still got a tree
I've still got a tree
nice I'm trying to get the bloody to 10 as well oh my god
your Chad bark I I should have been fighting you as Chad,
Chad, man!
Get those bullets bouncing.
Yeah, exactly.
We'll do bone.
Precision isn't 10.
It is because I got the achievement.
I got the achievement for it, I promise you.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Grab that.
Ouch!
I mean, I'll do it.
But I already got... See?
I didn't get achievement for it.
Uh-oh.
Oh, jeez.
I don't know if we'll survive this, everybody.
But if we do, I just want to say...
I love you.
I mean, wait.
If we don't, wait.
If we do, wait.
If we survive this...
I got something to tell you.
Chunk them cheats.
Chunk them cheats!
Chaco cheats!
Bloody tome to 10!
We did it.
Oh, I didn't get anything for it.
That's fine.
Oh, oh, oh, I think I'm done for it.
I think I'm done for it.
I think I'm...
I can't move.
I can't.
I have no shields.
I just gotta keep going in circles.
Oh!
It's okay.
Oh, I'm top 43%.
And we got three things.
Let's get some more cash.
Yeah, and let's unlock some stuff.
I'm so curious to get this bush guy.
It's just the end.
Nice run.
Yeah!
Good job, team.
Let's try him out.
Whoa!
Fire's piercing bullets.
I'm just gonna do him on like...
Whoa!
My god!
Tier 1 desert.
With a new guy.
Oh.
What were you shooting at?
There's all, there's mummies!
Whoa, great camo.
I know we're a bush in the desert.
We're a bush in the desert!
Speed, good for this level.
That's what I was thinking even.
Because it's all flat land.
That's what you're talking about.
about we need what's his name in this area oh actually it
wasn't one of the things like oh my god the way he's just
standing over there so creepy it said um we need uh what was
it bones we need the bones calcium in the desert we need to
beat him in the desert nice
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I couldn't, I couldn't afford the key.
That's okay.
I'm not only, actually, I'm not really not playing this so
well.
I'm just, uh, I'm just here to, um, I'm here to, uh, just
test him out a little bit.
Mawai.
Let's do, ah, you know what?
Oats.
Oats it up.
Size?
Oh dang it, whoa!
I'll take that.
What the heck is this?
It's so cute!
Big bullet from big gun.
Yeah, okay.
I wouldn't think the size matters.
No, my other...
Ouch.
I guess if we like land on the...
We land on the building, it's kind of nice.
Okay, bones.
No, come here, come here.
Oh, I'm too short for the building.
Ouch, I'm taking so much damage from...
Taking so much damage from...
From falling.
Sure.
Kill him!
Kill that guy!
No, kill that guy!
Yeah.
Open that.
Everything.
I can see everything.
It's kind of crazy.
Oh, what are these?
What are these?
They're so bizarre.
How bizarre?
How bizarre.
Me, me, me, me.
Now bizarre.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
They're bones.
They're like, uh, what's it called?
Like the dust.
I mean, uh, the things that like blow in the wind in the
desert.
But they're bones.
Tumbleweed!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a tumbleweed, but...
Not.
What is that?
Wait, is that the...
Oh, is this the challenge?
He's the push!
He's the push of this level!
I should have known.
Wait, what is the purple thing happening here?
Hey!
Dude, more lightning.
Holy cow!
I'm about to die, actually.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no!
Oh my god!
I'm playing Toho at the moment.
Scorpion!
I see!
I ran right into it.
The Bandit.
Who are you?
The Bandit!
Find and defeat the Bandit!
Panda, the desert.
Yeah, let's try again, but we'll do...
We'll do calcium.
Nice!
Oh!
Let's see.
A shady man just kind of...
I watched him, like, appear.
It was kind of funny.
Oh.
Lennox out.
I'll grab you.
What you got, buddy?
We gotta go beat up the Panda.
I'm scared.
One second.
Bob?
Who should we save up for?
We need cash.
Wait, what if I go in the water?
Is that good?
Whoa!
Oh.
I'm drowning?
Just kidding.
I'm a skeleton.
Woo!
Mega air!
Nice.
Hey, bone bros.
Just because you got a little bit more meat on ya doesn't
mean we can't be kind to each other big trick yeah let's do
crit chance tubular bro it might have been the sickest thing
you'll ever see in the wild wild west
my brain immediately went like precision tobe but i mean i'm
Actually, though, it's kind of good.
Kind of good, maybe.
Are you skateboarding on the sand?
Don't worry about it.
I need more, oh, projectile stuff, though.
Movements!
That was scary.
Do I have enough?
I don't think so.
We gotta go find the thing.
I forgot.
That's like the objective is to find the boss portal.
Oh my gosh.
Everything is health.
I want to come back for our guy though.
No, no.
Come on.
Take him out.
I need this money.
Thank you.
I might have enough now.
Hello.
Yes.
Oh, nice.
Bob!
Or...
Whoa.
Bob or gloves?
Slurp up?
Or Bob up?
I don't quite want the credit card.
I feel like the luck is not so good.
One, the blow-dog gloves.
They that good.
Oh.
There we go.
Epic lightning stuff.
Our first level up and it's epic.
Nice.
I think it's pretty fun that the enemies kind of randomize
each time too.
That's fun.
We'll get Bob another time.
Yeah!
Projectiles!
Yeah, yeah!
I don't have enough money.
Malai, do you have Bob?
No.
Yeah, it is fun to have variety.
Either are good for calcium, but lean towards HP recovery.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I wish I was slavery today, everybody.
Can I shall be home?
Don't say yarn.
Why is yarn such a powerful load?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, a real tumble.
Oh, I just got a katana.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, 5% chance to find a pot.
Wait, seriously?
I just got an achievement.
That was a 5% chance?
No way.
And I did it first try.
What the heck?
How?
Oh, wow!
Okay, good.
I was going to grab this health anyway.
That's crazy!
Bob!
Waif!
That was close.
I'm actually like a little too fast now.
Oh my gosh.
Quantity.
We got him.
We got him, team.
Cheese!
Oh my goodness.
Lucky pulls a little bit.
I think I'll go for that.
Max HP.
Oh, we found it, too.
We found it.
Very nice.
Moai.
Yon, you are weary now.
Others respond by yawning back.
Actually.
I'll get the key.
Jim's out.
Where are all my free...
Swarming coming?
I don't care.
I'm too fast to care.
Actually...
Oh, nice.
Where are all my free chests?
Let's duplicate.
Jeez.
I don't know what it got rid of.
I think it got rid of actually the...
I probably should upgrade my bone, huh?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
I know I can use it again, but I'm scared to go back there.
I'm a fragile guy.
The juice.
It did say it was a swarm.
Oh, here's a freebie.
Down!
Borger!
Oh, geez.
Ouch, ouch.
Killed 2,000 enemies using poison damage!
Holy cow, you guys!
Yes!
I need to, like, level up my, uh...
My weapons a bit.
Quantity.
Epic boy.
Nice.
Legendary stuff!
Bloody tome.
Let's use it again.
Let's get more cheese.
Okay, we got rid of our oats.
That's okay.
We cleared through the crowd.
That's awesome.
Yeah, we really are on a lucky streak.
more quantity please
and we're getting like some good oh my we're getting some
good achievements as well
we'll do luck always can have more luck moldy cheese always
can have more cheese too don't mind if I do Yeah, we've made
awesome progress in the game tonight.
Crit damage.
Wait, did we already kill that guy?
That's crazy.
Our build is kind of crazy.
Wait, I was- Oh, look how cute the cactuses are!
Wait, who's- Who's fighting that me?
Oh, it's these guys?
They have like a range attack?
Okay.
All right.
Literally on a roll.
I know.
Kind of insane.
Well, more beef ring.
Wow, okay.
Have I explored everything?
Not even a little bit.
This map is huge.
Let's go this way.
Everybody?
Now oats are good.
If only.
This is oats.
Oats.
I might be a prophet.
Manifesting food.
I am kind of hungry.
Luckily, I have some stuff after this.
To eat.
My katana will grow.
Projectile speed always confuses me for, like, attack speed,
you know?
Sounded a bit like you had work to do after this?
A little bit.
Actually, I will be off the next three days.
Unfortunately.
So I gotta get ready for that.
I have a question for you guys.
Actually, now that I brought it up.
Do you guys...
Do you guys prefer...
Like, I always feel bad when I put out a schedule, but I
have a lot of days off, you know?
So I'm like...
Do you guys still want me to put out a schedule even when I
have, like, you know...
More days off than usual?
You prefer to know?
Yeah, yes please?
Yeah?
Okay.
I just gotta come up with my schedule
Better than nothing Okay I realize also I forgot to post my
schedule on YouTube I'm so sorry Knowing helps Thank you,
Dorgo Also, I just saw Oh my gosh, Sehi Your don't know It
was from an hour ago I'm so sorry I mean, though Is it bad
that I kind of hoped that the connection was so bad
yesterday That you couldn't hear me?
No, I could hear you completely clearly I'm so happy I could
ramble at you for a bit.
You made me cry.
You were so sweet.
No!
Yeah, I'm gonna find you one day.
I only care about one stream and it's gonna be a next week's
schedule.
What are you talking about, Nan?
You're still here, aren't you?
That means you care about more than one stream.
Your little tsundere.
Yo, little tsundere.
Let's go for...
Evasion, maybe.
I don't know.
Kind of awkward.
Is this the challenge?
No, this is the boss curse.
Let's do the challenge so we can get more stuff.
Challenge!
Oh, wow.
We obliterated them.
Boy, that was kind of insane.
We absolutely...
challenge where?
Holy cow!
Let's go find another, an actual challenge maybe?
Uh...
Oh, hello.
Are you here to challenge me?
I wish I could find some more, um...
I guess let's go do the boss or something.
Epic bloody tone.
Yeah, this way.
It's kind of nice.
I've been getting my butt beat this entire time, so
honestly, having something where it's a little bit of like
me, you know, kicking butt and being super strong is a nice
change of pace.
Wow, so cute!
Lil Anubis.
Whoa, what are you doing?
Complete Desert Tier 1!
Yay!
Man, this is a weenia Jr. All right, here comes the, uh...
Epic Bone!
Wait, I want the Quantity Tone.
It's okay, though.
Yeah, Quantity Tone.
champ in our hearts.
Ah!
Quantity.
Well, I'm not used to it.
I wonder how far we can get in this, you know?
It might be pretty awesome.
I'm your little pog champ!
Poggers!
Attack speed is how fast you throw out each bone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Projectile is how fast your bones move around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I always see it.
I always see projectile speed, and I'm like, yes, that is my
attack speed.
But it's not, you know.
It confuses me.
Like, I know it.
But also, initially, I'm always like, oh, yeah, this is
that.
But it's not.
This is not that...
My katana.
I'm studying the blade.
I'm studying the blade!
We have a new weapon, though.
That's so exciting.
You're basically riding right now.
Lightning and blade?
Wait, you're so right.
Oh my gosh, we are basically riding right now.
That's kind of awesome.
Ouch.
How is the bone just now to projectile count to...
Whoa.
They're fast, but I am faster.
No, I'm not.
Just kidding.
I'm gonna go fast.
Oh, they're fast.
Oh, they're so fast.
Oh, I'm not faster.
I lied.
They're too fast.
Wait, they're too fast.
They're too fast!
I'm just getting pushed around like I'm a buggy boy.
Bumper!
Reach level 30 as calcium!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Weapon slots too!
Holy cow!
I got two more quests!
I got two more things!
Oh my gosh!
Huge!
Reach level 30 is calcium.
Complete desert tier 1.
We got a new character!
Kill 2,000 enemies using points of damage.
And the katana.
Vicky would be proud with how fast you went.
Gotta go fast.
That was an awesome run, everybody.
Good job.
Punch yourself on the back.
Whoa!
Let's unlock some things.
Oh.
Buy the weapon katana.
We can do that immediately.
Yeah, and we can buy you.
Yeah, and we can buy...
What else should I get?
I want to get whatever it was the poison.
This one?
Demonic soul?
Oh, I can't buy either.
That was the thing I was looking for earlier.
Weapon slot equals complete more quest.
Oh, so under here?
Yes.
Oh, I can't afford it at all.
Oh.
Battery is good.
What does it do?
125 silver.
Yeah, another weapon is huge.
We gotta save up for that.
Attack speed?
A boy.
Nice.
That's kind of awesome.
Well, guys, we made a super awesome progress today.
Wait, I do want to do like one fast run with our super
awesome new...
Wait, what does it do?
What's...
Execute a shot...
Oh, an enemy upon evading them.
Also, again, 0.5 evasion per level.
We'll do a quick run.
One last, one last.
Hey guys, I'm hungry and sleepy.
I'm hungry and sleepy.
I'm guessing, like, movement speed is so good, right?
To get...
I was spoiled with bones.
Mr. Bones.
Awesome, BG.
Yeah.
Wait till we eat peanut butter!
Gladly!
Let's do more size!
Size is good because our katana will be humongous.
A great size.
Holy cow.
A huge sword.
And I'm also gonna get, I'm gonna become Raiden again.
No, come back!
Thank you.
I'm gonna become, I'm gonna become Riden.
A little, little, little, little, little.
Ouch.
Sorry, I just ran right into him.
I thought he would attack.
I thought he would do something, but he chose not to.
Interesting choice.
Rules of Natak!
BD, BD, BD, BD, good job.
Love, Densetsu is gay.
Okay, yesterday.
Can't wait for the concert soon.
Wasada was not selected for the meet and greet.
No, yeah, there will always be more opportunities.
Don't you worry.
We will meet.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Oh, I missed him.
I missed out on him.
He's so slow.
Okay.
Kind of going insane.
But how slow he is.
Ouch.
Like, he just does not want to attack.
Ow.
And he gets one guy at a time.
I was trying to get him, but he's in the air.
Got too used to the bone boy.
Yeah, I was really good with him.
We were a good team.
You know what?
We put aside our differences.
Oh, wow.
But he's Naruto running.
How can he be slow?
That's what I'm saying.
I'm like, actually so confused.
Give me my loot.
Oh, I don't have any.
That's terrible.
Okay.
Man.
This is actually, like, really terrible.
This is the opposite of last...
of last run.
Do multi-cheese.
No chakra control yet.
What's happening when this happens?
Oh.
We're so...
This is so...
It's just our luck has not been great, you know, so just
kind of running in circles trying to get these guys.
Add them to the pile.
Oh, it's just a sandstone.
Please.
This kind of sucks.
Eventually.
Yeah, I'm gonna leave.
I give up.
Oh shoot, we're gonna...
Holy cow!
That was craziness.
Honestly...
Oh god.
Wait, there's the guy!
If I can't beat the boss though, there's no way I'm beating
the bandit.
Watch this.
That was a run.
That was a good taste test of him.
Okay, thank you guys so much for Mega Bonk today.
I had a lot of fun.
Oh, wow, we're so close to getting the lightning orb.
Oh, dang.
We'll get it next time.
Thanks for the streaming, good luck with whatever you got
going on in the next couple of days.
Thank you!
I'll be able to tell you guys about it sooner rather than
later, so that's exciting.
There you go, thank you so much for the peek!
I'm really sorry again about the confusion earlier.
No, no, no, it's here all good.
Here's an ill-timed beer.
I'm an apology.
Hope dinner's yummy.
Thank you!
If Ace Combat 8 is coming out, I hope they have Idol Master
skin.
I could destroy my enemies with cuteness.
I hope they have it again too.
Oh my gosh, I feel like they could with like Gakumash or
something.
Thanks for the stream.
I always call these types of games reverse bullet hells
because once you get powered up, you become a Toho boss.
That's...
Wait, that's such a good way of thinking of it, right?
Sometimes you play a rogue like.
Sometimes you play a rogue deal with it.
Otami-to!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Get something good to eat.
right to eat my tummy is thinking about it right now oh yeah
thank you everybody fake me thank you I will see you guys in
a couple of days then in a couple of days so sorry sorry I
almost did not go on this um like I almost did not do that
the thing that I'm going to do but then I decided I was like
you know what I I think I will do it.
I think I'll regret it if I don't, so...
Yeah.
No need to apologize.
But I always feel bad when I take off time.
Even if it's like something I need to do.
Take off, you know.
But yeah, thank you everybody!
Otumito!
Thank you so much, thank you so much!
See you guys later!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye-bye!
Yeah!
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Ah!
I'm over it.
Bye!